just let you guys know what the
tournament format here I'll they just
swap sides
skills asserted his dominance of the
Alfa Loki Loki he was just like you know
what I would take this seat actually I
can get out of your seat you actually
give me both these DX researches I like
them by the way go to dxracer come and
use a product code as well as your code
50% off on a dxracer chair but on top of
that though to get back to the point
just let you guys know the format of the
tournament sitting pretty in winter side
is skill that means he only needs to win
three games in order to win the
tournament blue god is Anna loser side
meaning that he has to win three games
to reset and then on top of that win
another three to win the tournament
that's right there's gonna be quite a
run but if anyone has a good chance of
doing that it's blue god he's on a hot
streak this is almost the exact this is
almost a repeat of the Evo run for him
as well where he was just tearing
through people in the loser's bracket
after losing yeah he and then like he
pushed you Toto kind of deal yeah pop
off that Eva were so great yeah this is
epic i by the way i got a little player
little late was like blue keep lighting
me for a second i just saw it
yeah yeah it was really hard to see
exactly what he was doing he was saying
hi is what we play oh yeah so here it is
this is the grand final hear the full
calendar six world Invitational skill
god i they're both character specialists
it's always been mitsurugi it's always
been as well after have a beautiful
thing to character loyalty always
teaches you so many things about the
play stuff because
chefs never sways right it's something
that's often character uw-stout but here
we go
heading into grid or anybody you got you
got to be ready for the lid you answer
my two aunts go get body the mix-up is
real I understand I got mixed I got
maybe four as well even starts playing
dude oh my god big as well and character
so like they already got cook so sold up
yeah okay so we've seen consecutive
matches and we haven't seen skill for a
little bit so I'm gonna talk about
what's been getting in this bar so
recently we've already talked about how
he personally believes his office Bell
how he looks at neutral doesn't want to
do big leads right he is completely okay
with getting stray hints you know just
be be right AAA and just racking up that
damage into maybe putting you into a
situation where they're like oh crap
dude I'm just I'm just racking up to
hitch I gotta do something and then
that's when he initiates the big big hit
and that's what's been doing so far is
just straight-up patience rate strongly
getting started game one skill versus
blue god and I mean this is one of the
favorite where a lot of people really
worry about having to fight as well on
it because we can switch dances or
whatever he wants because of how large
it is right he was able to get at round
star sorry baby boy take a bubble bath
let's go
that was so fast and look he can get
sort or whatever weapon he wants for
just a little bit of damage to him not a
lot just a small amount maybe depending
nice tuck on that he's a hot to list
though it's gonna be a little bit scary
blocks on the locusts the 6p comes out
and then the challenge from skill
doesn't respect just whip it though Bane
gently that skillfully of mad damage Oh
jaws a little bit of BB action I like it
I'd like it yeah I mean look at all the
stray hits that led to this amount of
damage right like he's so far ahead but
stray hits coming back from the Evod as
well who's gonna use those soul cards to
do maybe minister now to come back and
wow just because it's the soul charge
when they go so much farther however
skill punishment
has also one meter to work with coming
into this ramp without already burning
him but let's see what happens oh wow
please go ahead okay
set up afterwards comes a stance not to
throw out of stance all right they try
to shiny climbing no big inhale a heart
do that I like it though trying to put
itself in almighty you want to you want
to speed here we go get my free launch
on OT okay oh what a block level of
supposed to get Agassi's and guts all
blocks below and the hell sweep is able
to punish with the AP and I mean that's
kind of just the thing that you that you
run into sometimes you have to kind of
roll the die on that and if you die
still regardless forcing the full charge
of out of skills baby no yeah for a
second that I was looking pretty dire
for blue vada and I'm elated looking
great and right now for still he was if
it gave a couple of hits he breaks the
throw his sword stance it before move on
so you got to watch out AAA you got the
shoulder check and there it is runs up
and he tries to get himself as strong of
a start as he possibly can
yeah Burnett soldier gracious like that
okay
the re comes out on the 6ba give me the
go
sidestep these people to hit him out of
it yo look at this pressure right now
we're advocating two meters what I saw
people hit but okay was so close okay I
got mad tight over that one but here we
go
okay so charge showing the power of
reason there's two bars available skills
well yeah he was just waiting for
whatever the mix-up option possibly was
so you can ensure that the hit not a
clean hit on that one all blocks the low
and there's the launcher and that's kind
of do it what a punish for blue god you
had talked about how he's just the god
of punishing that was amazing exactly no
he's about one game can he do it though
one step at a time
what step at a time each game counts
every round counts skill taking a moment
there we're in a new stage oh yeah kind
of stage with that break up a wall
that's correct so yeah you know what you
want to get out of you want to get out
of India for it especially when it comes
to you do not want to give as well a
chance to just be able to freely get so
let's dance whatever he wants it's just
not fun time okay nice block on this
what what a step he got half the six
beat it's the full conversion right
there before Singh him at the wall and
then I can't disrespect right there from
the body did not care afterwards oh my
god the pressure right now
again I bear it is finally okay this is
blue got mixing it up he's no longer
talking about I'm gonna do the mid
option six times in a row and save the
lowest for lack
he used to point out on the stop right
here and right now alright good pressure
it against his body a time one time
walk down the middle okay there it is
still mounting it offense he's got the
life leadership wings put them up
against the wall and we're gonna see if
lugod disrespects like you did last time
trying to stuff all right bills the
meters getting his what to work with
another win oh yeah while he actually
tried to use the whip on a normal on him
but he ended up getting punished on the
start up of this what it step right
there he was able to catch it throwing
knives got him round one round a piece
right now coming into the second game I
both have matching media to work with
here but soul trying to get away from me
good pressure you know that covers a lot
of options right there actually so I
really like that he went towards it on
the thing is it does use a lot of
Colgate oh wow what a interrupt right
there from get one spot oh good lord
here we go combos baby oh oh he chops it
again but I think that's the second time
that's happened on the state could be
delayed could have been like a slight
miss spacing oh my god yeah he's in
stance so it makes sense right
I got meters my love what are you doing
over there
yeah after after see he is in shorts
pants it's not like in vanilla wait here
we got all my Oh got it
yeah yeah maybe but still stayin alive
blue God scrapping it out and there's
the mid right now one of these in games
not just rounds no more still looking
good I wonder if we're gonna see a
random stage
try and get something a little bit
bigger as well as as well as always
gonna love those stages where he can
just switch stances freely I love I just
want to go and should I hate them
somebody's a little bouncy up and down
just jealous yes right get into it let's
go I'm gonna stick into it right here
he's gonna go for the throw the funnest
game comes down and all my god does
neither have been slapping each other so
check coming out
goes back me where it out to infinity
and so much working I was oh and it's
the sphere is Gilad tried to actually
use his eye his to start up on his
stance to get we got into doing
something didn't work out as a car
broken all right go mad damage with the
follow-up though okay
chicka angry hey nice walk on that yeah
whatever you can't be all you miss the
lethal hit let me go get the long flight
they - there's a mix of situation
Yannick just said oh there it is but
nice block right there full punish
situation he got the grab that was big
from skill very few crabs coming out
from him in those situations from what I
remember it so I can't I can't believe
you got being ready for it and running
every time she looks kills momentum just
Alex re straight off around that spicy
nobody's a lot more patient than that
but no so he's thinking a little bit
more larger wrist beautiful sights done
by blue guys challenging that our egos
no you can't get that if I'm all the way
on your side my guy yeah I mean you know
that was one of the risks you're talking
about right there
that are he oh my god job leave the
walls but I'm gift that extra damage for
just noodle to no reason basically all
my goodness jumps over it all sets up
the bubble and there you go okay you
know what though a boy got two meters to
work with right now yeah he actually
does have a grip still a physical
advantage you know I've burned the
meeting you guys to spend maybe spend
the money
I cannot believe his backside in the
saloon didn't clean it luckily for skill
cook you know he was at the wall right
there okay trying to catch him trying to
get as much damage out of this old chard
and I mean he got over half his life I
think that was a good soul card
yeah if you're sure was what money well
spent
okay check on that for this time break
attack comes out though able to actually
hit the low option as well punished hold
a step when he actually tech crept under
the five a very very lucky in that
situation boy is just shoutouts jumping
[Music]
man that man mastered the dodge skills
that has been that bastard brother and
he just beautiful looks like boo God was
looking at the GI immediately but skill
had sidestepped first and I'm gonna get
the lethal hit here big damage
potentially I mean
he's working on two bonds to build right
yeah okay right now and he's at the wall
so of course it's gonna soul talk right
he stopped at the bar to work with he's
gonna hit him directly out of any
beyblade he does so that that's why do
God's not doing anything right he wants
to do it in a situation where he's just
not ready for it and that's exactly what
it was good if he's somehow still got
hit okay is a block on this and that's a
free punish right there for blue god
look at the damage
still still alive don't kind of mode
just yet although one is right there on
the guard impact from Stan's situation
for him that's why he started out an
almighty as for possible he got the six
BB in you put him right back into red
card James I don't care how much you
regain but they're all my goodness now
ring outs are a possibility for both
players if they're your body at them of
your sword fails yep I like these
tactics Oh Almighty get stops and wait
that might have been yeah I was gonna
say that seemed a little bit late yeah
he actually didn't even need the ring
out here he got him before he could you
can bring him out and so he took some
duck corpses homies that's an aesthetic
okay he likes to just do that he's been
playing graveyard keeper I feel like oh
say casket for you I bet boom one right
now for skills same stage and in the
same situation wafak no one wants to
touch you know
believe it or not Ari doesn't start it
alright here we go a little too far away
from the wall see anything special from
that by the walls there's at least a
little bit of pressure on him you know
speaking of pressure bag it's a waltz
left there thank ya I tried to fake the
other multiples on that one is one 403b
good damage I saw oh my goodness oh nice
good setup right there all right so we
got so try to see you're live right now
rounds away we actually would have been
tired okay goes under it right now
I mean you're sitting pretty on this
round for sure like the skill is
controlling it nice recognizing the
stamp change that he can chew a right
there right Oh got the hit okay punish
that one around the piece here in what
could be a tournament winning game runs
up soul card trying to make it happen
right now to move on
it's done gurgi pressure but no filter
just get away from me I don't want to
deal with this yeah I mean it's pretty
shocking you're gonna happen a couple of
times where you like are still available
for skillet 16 put your work in it oh my
goodness right now and I can bet that he
smells blood here we go okay Newsweek
resume one stick of butter here one guy
separator residents high hell trying to
stay alive right now fighting for his
life yeah he does not want to give skill
a chance to be able to put him on the
back foot and I all goodness is close to
the legend that forces the sole charge
out he's probably gonna start stepping
yeah
all right happen on the returns over
there he was trying to oh goodness what
a punish on that skill remaining so
incredibly consistent throughout the
entire thing
ski stuck to that game plan of just as
long as I can get you to hang yourself
I'll hit you with Hayes bb's and then
you'll start freaking out and I got you
don't worry my god skill just won the
Soul Calibur world Invitational and I
gotta be rude so like skill has
definitely been one of the most
consistent players out of most of the
people in this coffee like so so most
consistent players being skilled
Blubaugh and shanshan etc all right
he showed up today he absolutely showed
up he's coughing he can't breathe this
poor guy I'm gonna get him inhaler oh my
goodness he deserves all the oxygen
right now okay chat he deserves this
yeah so that is what an incredible job
calendar world invitational finally done
skills gonna be able to take it over
blue god and in third place is gonna be
the lolo mix going down what a
tournament every every match was just
was just like heart heart like we attack
him through the table we're just like oh
my god Oh close situation to bring outs
where we were just like oh my god it's
gonna happen you know as well get some
muscle Buster next to the wall and we're
like man is that guy dead yeah I think
he's dead no he dropped it we're like oh
okay then okay we're living
okay what's gonna happen then right so
it's like going through the situations
time and time again incredible stuff
like wow like and just see just to see
the passion right behind all those
players seen them hug it out and like
especially when I'm after to get hard
lost like that just the compassion
between people and be like you know what
we're all friends here yeah we're all
top-level competitors but we're all here
together as a part of the FTC the
fighting game community and you know you
can't do without having friendship and
really awesome trading partners and just
loving each other